[Music]
oh
i'll lend you a hand so in exchange
in exchange
oh i need to put it in here
please make my baby whole again
[Music]
that was weird
i thought for a second that my character
was just falling into place
in the world
no i'm just going down
oh i'm getting dizzy need to stop
[Music]
don't worry about the kid even it'll be
fine
just get your ass across the bridge
it'll she will
okay
ah ethan winters
welcome i didn't think you'd make it
past
daughter moreau but i suppose you
survive worse back in america
i like you i'd like to speak to you
about rose
and miranda oh come on in
don't worry it's not a trap
shut up what are you planning it's
totally a trap
it's not a trap it's not a trap
clay's here austin aries tonight
i don't think there'll be anything to
pick up really i think this is
the introduction to heisenberg so i need
to just
go in but
ah this place doesn't look as pretty
hello
i'll take this hope you don't mind
hasn't been
just taking some gum powder
i already need some shotgun shells that
would be very nice
this looks like a save room but it's not
weird
what's behind the curtain what'd you
hide in there
what the hell mia
chris truth hurts
let me guess you're thinking take me out
like the others and then he gets going
save rose right
i'm healing my daughter look
you got the soul wrong
listen ethan you're being played
what are you talking about you think
this is a game
i said
lady super-sized [ __ ]
ugly ass psycho doll an ammonic freak
don't you get it it's a test
to see if you're strong enough to be a
part of miranda's family i don't want to
be a part of miranda's family neither
did i but here we are
and i'm next in line right kill me
move up the chain well [ __ ] that
i don't give a damn about your personal
issues
i just want to fix my daughter so do i
do you have any idea how powerful a kid
is even miranda
scared her
last time you freaked i swear to god
who's down there
you and me together we go save rose and
we can use her
to grind miranda into beast my daughter
is not a weapon no no ethan we say yes
and then
we turn on him later
last chance yes you don't want to find
out what's in that hole
no i'll take my chances oh for [ __ ]
sake ethan
you're here
why ethan why
for [ __ ] sake [ __ ] jesus
can i get under here no oh [ __ ] jesus
where do i go then
what am i supposed to do how do i do it
i'm gonna die
i don't know what i'm supposed to do
okay there must have been somewhere else
to go
it look like if you crawl under those
pipes though
shut this way
this way have a look around can i go
this way
oh god all right that's going that way
can i go in this way
no am i calling moving
yeah what the hell james
i tried twice to get under those pipes
before and
ethan just stood back up when i tried to
go under that's so weird
what was that thing oh
did i miss something to pick up yes
somewhere
ah here
oh the club
i'm liking all this crap
wait do they like explode or something
are there something experiments that
are they blind
thanks for the skull
that's right
i can make some stuff
obviously i'm gonna make this
uh
this place is messed up whoa gotta get
upstairs
like manufacturing them wow
master
i guess
oh hello duke how are you i did
how do you get everywhere what is it
with you
why are you everywhere
well then feel free to peruse
thank you for your patronage
you're welcome
so i guess we gotta find a way to turn
on the power to
use that elevator
i'll leave behind the door
okay what i'll do
i'll place a line
right on the floor
because we know they're stupid and they
gonna set up the mines
bit further back
oh so much beeping
did both of them just go off [ __ ] sake
that's what i was hoping wasn't gonna
happen
no i should probably shouldn't shoot you
in the face because then you
can see me so this goes against
everything that
i know as a gamer don't shoot you in the
head
i think can't believe both of mines just
went off
before pressing any buttons let's
explore a little bit
[Applause]
don't shoot them in the face only shoot
them in the legs
or maybe in the butt or is the groin
anywhere that hurts but not in your head
maybe i should press that button
you press the button exercise no
maybe we should press the button let's
go press the button
oh there's not enough power
hello
what
is that uh them oh what's this
i don't think i can put anything in here
not yet anyway
is this a clue of some sort
oh yeah have that photo of that fish
it's not from this side
so
um
damn it i want to try and kill someone
with only an iphone
a lot of hits
huh oh is it okay
what's in there yellow cords
oh wait maybe that's for the uh oh
is it for the necklace
no no
i was really hoping it'd be for the next
one okay whatever
how we doing health
what's uh
that doesn't look good
i'm not doing too good on ammo either
do you usually have to make handgun ammo
that's
rare so i don't want to make another
mine or
ah
hi uh
i don't mean to disturb you sleeping i'm
just
passing through
oh god this is not eternity
it's not gonna be good in a minute
maybe i should get my big gun
i was really expecting that to either
wake him up or
for him to have moved and he hasn't
which is weird
[ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] but the
[ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] for the [ __ ] for the
[ __ ]
but the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
[ __ ] the [ __ ] that the [ __ ] with the
[ __ ]
put the [ __ ] for the pizza [ __ ] this
oh crap yeah stop i don't already have
much ammo
uh for the ship for the fish for
cheers
is he coming or not
seems useful
yes ethan very useful why are you just
like
i guess it seems useful he's just so
chill
and i'm really not okay uh
oh yes
goodbye
i'm i'm not used to my hand gun being so
low on ammo
come on ethan do you think yeah
that was it that was the thing
oh that was a massive monster it's just
gears
maybe if i shoot them they stop
let's see what this is all about i want
any special key
special horsey key let's get in here
with a big box
hmm new weapon possibly
i don't have a lockpick
it's my theory corrector am i just going
to wait down here
freaking pipe in the way
my theory is correct
oh [ __ ] enough i was supposed to climb
back up not fall down
oh god no
[Music]
get me back up please
i've just got one more to stop
oh that's a lot of them
[ __ ]
okay
oh one more
nice
oh my god there's loads of them
oh thank you for following fox tombow
appreciate it i'm just i'm just uh
shooting shooting some some lights
and worrying that all my ammo is gonna
be gone wait hold up
and get them both in a similar place
hey
starting to have to be cautious
about my ammo
but maybe this will help oh
[ __ ] sake
i want something good
okay that's better than nothing
i mean i'm still not gonna make hangar
now
because i'm probably going to find that
more than anything else
i was trying to get you in the back i
could be a little stealthy stealth
sneaky sneak but it didn't work
[ __ ] it out
okay now i'm out of finger mama damn
damn damn
damn um
it's fine we're okay
we got all our big guns
do i want to make some because i could
make some but
something's like no i'm not
making hanger man hang
i refuse um i do however need to
there should be a light somewhere out
there
oh that's why i was shooting at them
uh my accent is actually plymouthian
but i dip into so many accents
when i'm playing especially horror games
people will tell you i'll go from like
crappy irish to crappy scottish to
sometimes australian northern
i don't even know
but i'm from plymouth
oh well i
well well wow
it's locked from the other side of
course it is
yep they're gonna come to life they're
all gonna come to life and it's gonna be
grand i can't wait
it's going to be a great party
oh cool well duke's just up there so we
could go back and say hi
but first let's explore here
wait was that what i thought it was yes
okay
backup generator i need to cog
anything down here to me
gosh this place seems to just go on and
on and on
there's a breakable wall back there that
i need i need to break
do you think i can break it with my
knife so i don't have to waste any of my
explosives
probably not but we can try
no okay fine then
um i can i can use this
i do have yeah
ah sweet
thanks for the extra shotgun am i always
appreciated
and now i have this part so you to you
wait where is it that i just picked up
wait am i being stupid i just thought i
just picked up like a cog or something
oh it's just a piece of junk that i can
sell but i can also
combine it with something
but i can't use it for gameplay okay
i should probably go back but i don't
want to
it's telling me to craft ammo
you might want to craft some ammo dude
just saying okay
i feel like i should just run back and
quickly
yeah fine fine fine fine game i'm just
gonna run back to duke
save the game then i'll come back here
also that button up here should work now
shouldn't it
ah fair enough
is it this way
oh my gosh he's fell away than i thought
he was
there you are naturally
okay i want to sell
this uh not these because i can combine
them
even though i really don't think i'm
going to find the other decks this part
but
uh yeah if it's not done i guess odd
times ethan
i just don't have any new any nude for
jewels
any nude for you young girl
used to be alive can you not chew in my
ear please it's really rude
i hate it when he says that
okay
can i buy anything for my guns
this is all an investment ethan
an interesting selection
please come again right stay quickly
so
this music is so weird
has it like
okay we're going in
let's get to half
mechanical soldier sold at
fully grown version 1.0
polygram male corpse used removed hearts
and implanted caddo muscle stimulation
via electric
shock was successful brain dead so no
high cognitive ability
only moves by destructive instinct then
stops
mechanical soldiers sold at version 1.01
attached headgear to the cranium ex
electrocute
electro electrodes
confirm stable brainwaves experiment one
lichen fight was dismantled and eaten
within
three minutes oh damn these are really
powerful people
issues with destructive and murderous
capabilities
mechanical soldier sold out so these are
all the the men outside i guess
that are just hanging outside um
replaced lower parts of arm with drill
not enough output for effective movement
need live bodies perhaps
mechanical soldier sold out implanted
caddo reactor into the chest output
greatly increased
experiment two like in fight destroyed
three leggings in one minute
dying good results for issues with
reactor durability
may stop functioning if the reactor is
destroyed we noticed that with the
with the guy who woke up i was shooting
at his as his
chest and uh yeah it's definitely
affecting it
okay
he's gonna come back though isn't he
oh oh that's so that good
for one minute i was like they're gone
but no they're still there
hello man i'm not scared of you
[ __ ] jesus christ i am scared of you
i'm scared of you i'm scared of all of
you i'm scared of you
i lied i'm so bad
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god
that was cool
that was cool
yeah i like that
um okay
i knew something was gonna happen there
i was just trying to psych myself out
i'll hype myself up so where does this
wheel have to go
to the previous place
where was the previous place oh god
getting so confused by the vast amount
of rooms i don't know i don't want to be
in with you guys i don't like you guys
there's a park and it's needed somewhere
and i know i was near the duke but i
just gotta remember where
it was definitely through here
and then it was definitely one of these
ways
oh jesus
yeah it was still here here
why why is it loud noises
i don't like them oh
ethan such a disappointment why
miranda truly
truly disappointed
forgot to be her children
she locked us away in the village
i don't care about your mummy-ish shoes
i'm not like my siblings
i want nothing more than to be free of
that [ __ ]
so i need power
i need enough power to destroy her
pommy's like why don't we just team up
are the fruits of my
power the strong will destroy the
weakness that's the way of the world
you should have never refused me ethan
i know i'm sorry to think about myself
as well
what a freak ethan's like nah
he has no regrets
okay
i just keep checking all the time i want
more ammunition please
ah
whatever he goes oh god oh god
oh god turn around ethan
how are you doing oh you're right you're
right okay
oh was this something that would have
helped me
possibly
sniper rifle what what
this game has just suddenly gone from
giving me handgun ammo and
hardly anything else to just all the
other ammos
so maybe i will have to make some
handgun this is so surreal
okay
uh where am i going up the stairs i
guess
which one either it probably doesn't
matter
[ __ ] hell of course
i have no no explosion is
why don't you
what the [ __ ] did you just shoot at
i need i miss my pistols
oh my god i don't even have any ammo i
mean any help
we all know i have no ammo why can't i
close that i don't care
where is him from
[Applause]
okay that worked
let's just keep going around doing that
stop it stop hiding the goods
oh no you can only use it once
now that's cheating
um
look it's back back again
huh
i was so worried i
honestly was not too sure about that
situation
ah damn
okay
need some help please
my mind's nice and everything but i need
some
bullets and health and oh crap
i don't feel very confident
i'm so glad ethan doesn't get hurt by
those mines
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] how am i using
my good ammo i need ice
oh no i'm gonna have to choose health
over ammo because
i but need need
cannot believe
this is the first time throughout the
whole game that i've been like
really in need of some ammo
[Music]
hello
oh no no [ __ ] things
there wasn't even any ammo in here for
me
okay i have two there and i have some
flash bangs
this is on his back oh [ __ ] off you
little [ __ ] bag
i got it i got it
[Applause]
oh this is gonna be so hard cause this
gun is so [ __ ] precise
get me some [ __ ] ammo now
all right what does it give me shotgun
oh you beautiful okay
i do have that one
ah
oh
this is getting so stressful now it's
getting too close
[Applause]
hey thanks tommo right
apologies for my anger
people it's just it's getting real i
have hardly any help
i have i have no uh
medicine and
how did he have it
oh my god we're back here
[Music]
hallelujah let's just um run back to
the duke is it this way yeah
he probably would have been in front of
us anyway but i'm gonna run back here to
the duke
hey duke look at me i'm nearly dead
naturally take
all of these please all of my crystal
mechanical hearts
pay me no mind
[Music]
yes please
i need some of these i need some news
an interesting selection i have i want
all of the ammo
give me holiday ammo um
give me this thank you for your purchase
oddly enough to do this
i saw you eyeing that one
good day then
all right now let's get this one back
out
uh and this one back to here
and then what was down the bottom again
oh it was you wasn't it
right there and life is back to how it
once was
beautiful oh yeah
let's see
that's a lot of shotguns yes quality
influencer i
love my shotgun uh let's
carry on through here
i'm so glad we're done with that i'm so
glad we're done with that
i don't even know how i managed to
survive that honestly
that was tough
sweet
oh no is there another one
it's fine we're fine
where's your thingy on your back okay
well wait let me get around you oh for
foxy
jesus jesus jesus jesus jesus
hello
hello i see you
hello
range on
[ __ ] sake range on music
yes i won you guys
gone out of my life go go leave
never come back
now
jesus christ no oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh my god i gotta go to god
examine examine
oh okay
oh
oh there's a yellow box up there
did i miss that i haven't gone there yet
i don't know what it does yet
what am i doing oh hello duke
okay tell you what this is a good place
to leave it we've been
we've been streaming for a long time
consistent patronage
i've expanded my services
yes
have a wonderful adventure well i always
think
right okay we're saving
and we're leaving
thank you so much for sticking out with
me
and sorry to your ear holes if
i heard them today
[Music]
and i stream every thursday 8
30 pm bst so
yeah i will see you next thursday